KAZ SATO: Hello.
Thank you for taking your
time on our session, How
to build a smart RasPi bot with
Cloud Vision and Speech API.
I'm Kaz Sato.
I'm a developer out of gate
for Google Cloud platform.
And--
GLEN SHIRES: And
I'm Glen Shires.
I'm a software engineer
on the Cloud Speech API.
KAZ SATO: OK.
I'd like to show a demonstration
video of the Cloud Vision Bot,
at first, So let
me share the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Cloud Vision provides powerful
image analytics capabilities
as easy-to-use APIs.
It enables
application developers
to build the next
generation of application
that can see and understand
the content within the images.
The service is built on
powerful computer vision
models that power several
different Google services.
The service enables
developers to detect
a broad set of entities
within an image,
from everyday objects to
faces and product logos.
The service is so easy to use.
As one example of
the use cases, you
can have any Raspberry
PI robot, like GoPiGo,
calling the Cloud
Vision API directly.
So the bot can send the
images taken by its camera
to the cloud, and can get the
analysis result in real time.
It detect faces in the image,
along with the associated
emotions.
The Cloud Vision API is
also able to detect entities
within the image.
Now, let's see how
facial detection works.
Cloud Vision detects
faces on the picture,
and returns the positions
of eyes, nose and mouth.
So you can program the
bot to follow the face.
[ROBOT BEEPING]
It also detects emotions
such as joy, anger, surprise
and sorrow.
So the bot can move
toward smiling faces,
or avoid anger or
surprised face.
One of the very interesting
features of Cloud Vision API
is the entity detection.
That means it detects
any abject you like.
Let's see how it works.
-It's glasses.
It's banana.
It's automobile.
It's money.
-You see?
Cloud Vision lets
developers to take advantage
of Google's latest machine
learning technologies
quite easily.
Please go to
cloud.google.com/vision
to learn more.
[END PLAYBACK]
KAZ SATO: So that was
the demonstration video
for Cloud Vision bots.
So I'd like to
discuss how to build
this bot by using the Vision
API in these sessions.
But I'd like to start
briefly discussing
about the machine intelligence
working behind the bot.
GLEN SHIRES: Do
you want to get--
KAZ SATO: OK.
Thank you.
So we are using a technology
called neural networks.
So what is neural network?
Neural network is
a function that
can learn from the
training data set.
So it's designed to mimic
the behavior of neurons
inside human brain by using
the matrix operations.
For example, if you want to
do the image recognitions
with neural networks,
then you can
convert your input image,
such as cat images,
into a Raj vector, and
then put that vector
to the neural
networks, where it does
the massive amount of
the matrix operations,
such as the match applications
or additions between vectors
and matrices.
And then, eventually, you'd
have another large vector
as an output, which represents
the levels of the objects
detected in an image, such
as the cat, or automobile,
or the human face.
So let's take a look
at another example, how
neural network works, by
using the dataset called
double spiral.
In this double
spiral data set, we
have two groups of
the data points.
One is the orange group,
then another is blue group.
If you are a
programmer, and if you
are asked to classify those data
points, what kind of a program
code you would write?
Do you want to write
many if statements
or [INAUDIBLE]
statements to classify
each location with the
points by using the condition
and the thresholds?
Do you want to write that?
I don't want you to
write that kind of code.
Instead, I would be using
machine learning or neural
networks, so that I can let
the computer try to find a way
to solve this problem.
So let's take a look
at the demonstration.
This is a demonstration
called the Playground, where
you can just, actually, running
the neural networks to solve
this problem.
Now you are seeing,
the computer is
trying to find the
optimal combination
of the parameters inside neural
networks to solve this problem.
Actually, it's not working
right, so let's try it again.
Sometimes the machine
learning fails,
so you have to try
multiple times.
Now here you go.
The computer found
a way to combine
the parameters in
an optimal way to do
the classification with
the double spiral datasets.
So this is how neural networks
works to solve your problem,
rather than instructing
the computers how
to solve the problem by humans.
OK, go back to this slide.
And you can apply these
neural network technologies
to solve much more complex
problems, such as recognizing
a cat in an image or
recognizing pedestrians
walking around the street.
You can do that, but you have
to have many more hidden layers,
the layers inside the input
vector and output vector.
So it takes a long time
to finish training.
That is called deep neural
networks, or deep learnings.
But the largest problems right
now for deep neural networks
is the computational resource.
It usually takes a few
days or a few weeks,
sometimes, to finish
your trainings
with deep neural network.
So that's the reason
why Google has
been researching on
distributed training
by using the Google Cloud.
By using the GPUs or TPUs, that
can shorten the training times
in order of 1/10 or 1/100.
And that is the reason why
Google has been so successful
applying the deep neural
network technologies
to the many consumer
services, such as the voice
recognitions with
Android devices,
or the image recognitions
with Google [INAUDIBLE],
or the ranking in the
Google search services.
Now, we have over 20 products
and services at Google that
have been using the deep
learning [? technologies ?]
[? underlying. ?]
And now, we have
started to externalize
the power of the neural
networks running on Google
Cloud to external developers.
The first product is
called Cloud Vision API,
and the second product is
called Cloud Speech API.
What is Cloud Vision API?
Cloud Vision API is an
image analysis service that
provides the pre-trained model.
So you don't have to train
your own neural networks
or machine learning model.
Rather than that, you can
just use the REST API,
just sending your own
images uploaded to the API.
Then, you are going to
be receiving the analysis
result in a JSON format
in a few seconds.
So you don't have to have any
machine learning skill set
or experience, and
it's so inexpensive.
It only costs $2.50 per
1000 units or images,
and it takes no charge to
start trying out the API.
So let's look at another
demonstration for Cloud Vision
API.
Here, I'm launching a
demonstration called
Cloud Vision Explorer, where
we have imported over 80,000
images from Wikimedia commons,
uploaded on the Google Cloud
storage, and applied the
Vision API analysis already.
And by using the result
of the Vision API,
we have done
clustering analysis,
so that you are seeing
the cluster of the images,
such as sea cluster, or
snow cluster, or estate
or residential area cluster.
And if you take a look
at the cluster for cats,
then you'll be seeing the
many images that is classified
as a cat, like these.
If you put these
images through the API,
the API will be sending back
the results, such as the cat,
or pet, or this must
be a British shorthair.
All those results will be
returned in the JSON format
like this.
But in these demonstrations, you
can see them in a graphical UI.
Also, if your image
has text inside it,
then the API can convert
the text inside the images
to a string, like this,
with tree kangaroos crossing
next two kilometers.
You can get it as a string.
Or if you have the
faces in your images,
then the API can detect
the faces and the locations
of each face, and also the
emotions of each faces,
such as joy, or sorrow,
anger, or surprise.
So you can easily find which
face is smiling or not.
If your image contains
very popular locations,
then it can provide the name
of the popular location,
such as the Citi Field stadium
in New York City with longitude
and latitude.
You can even put a
marker on Google Maps.
Oh, sorry.
You can even use the product
logo detection features
so that you can
easily understand
the image has the product
logo or corporate logo.
So there was the demonstrations
of the Vision API.
So let's take a look at how
you can bring this machine
intelligence into details
the Raspberry Pi bot.
So Cloud Vision bot is
based on a Raspberry Pi
robot called GoPiGo, which is
produced by Dexter Industries.
So you can go to
Dexter's website
to buy GoPiGo at around $200.
And also, you may want
to buy a fisheye camera
to capture the wider range
of views surrounding the bot.
And we have written a few of
handwritten lines of Python
code to capture the
image from my camera
and send the image to the API.
It's really easy
to start getting
started with the Vision API.
You can just go to
cloud.google.com/vision
to getting started.
You can try the
Quickstart tutorial,
and that should be
finished within 30 minutes.
This is a sample of Python
code to send your image
data to the API.
You have to convert the image
binaries into the base 64 text,
and embed that text
into the content
property of the request.
And also, you have to specify
the types of the features you
want to detect.
In this case, it's specified
the label detections
as the features,
so that you will
be receiving the labels as a
result of the API analysis.
And you can make
the call to the API.
Then, you will be receiving the
result, JSON, in a few seconds,
so that you can easily
dig into the JSON result
to getting out the labels.
If you specify face
detection, then you'll
be receiving the positions
of the face, and landmarks,
such as the boundingPoly
properties, where you would
have the x and y positions.
And also, you will have
the joylikelihood property,
where you can find each
face is smiling or not.
So it's really easy to
write a Python code to turn
the bot into the
direction of the face,
and also if it's
smiling, then you
can run the motors of the
bot to follow the person.
So let's take a look at the real
demonstration of the Vision API
bot.
So I'm showing the console.
So this is the user interface
web console for the bot.
So actually, it's showing the
vision it is taking right now.
Not sure it's working or not.
Must be working.
I hope it's working.
Is it working?
Not sure.
Let me try.
So if you put the flowers--
it's not saying anything.
So it looks like it's
not working anymore.
Maybe I can try
fixing this stuff.
So while doing that, maybe
I can pass the stage to him.
GLEN SHIRES: OK.
So you want me to
jump into my slides?
KAZ SATO: Yeah.
GLEN SHIRES: OK.
Yeah.
Hi.
So I'd also like to talk about
the Cloud Speech API, which
is actually a rather new API.
It was released about
a month and a half ago,
and it joins a
number of speech APIs
that Google has had for
quite some time, quite
a number of years.
You're probably familiar with
the Android Speech API, which
allows you to do speech-to-text
and text-to-speech on Android
devices, phones,
tablets, autos, TV, etc.
So that's in Java.
That's a Java-based API.
There's also the Web
Speech API, which
is in Chrome, which is a
JavaScript-based API that
allows you to do speech.
And the Cloud Speech
API is a new API
that we've released that allows
you to put this on any device.
So whatever device or server
you'd like to put speech into,
we've made it very
easy, and we support
quite a number of languages.
So we've made it very
easy to integrate this
into all sorts of different
clients and servers.
The Cloud Speech API is powered
by Google's machine learning.
So we've got a lot of
experience with speech,
and we've built that
all into the API.
So the same powerful engine
that you have on Android,
you have on Chrome, you now have
available for whatever project
you'd like to use it on.
The models are
pre-trained, so you do not
have to learn machine learning
to specifically use it.
You can just get up and
running immediately.
And it supports over 80
languages and variants
of languages.
It's got real-time streaming.
And so, what real-time streaming
means is that, as I'm talking,
the text is actually coming
out while I'm talking.
And what I'd like to do is
give you a quick demo of that.
So I'm sure you're familiar
with this page, which has speech
on it, Google search page.
Web Speech API.
What I'm doing here is pulling
up a demonstration page
for the Chrome Web Speech API.
And make it a little
bit bigger here.
So what I'm going to
do is, as I'm talking,
I want you to notice that
the words are coming out.
And actually, first,
they'll be gray words,
because it's not
quite sure, then
when it's very confident of the
words, it turns them to black.
So you can see, as I'm speaking,
the words are coming out
and appearing on the screen.
They turn black after it's
very confident of what I said.
And where's the presentation?
OK.
So that's an example of the
real-time streaming that's
built in.
And we have a limited
preview right now,
which you can sign
up and join and start
using the Cloud Speech API.
Cloud Speech API is
actually two different
API, or at least two
versions of the same API,
is probably a better
way to put it.
There's a REST API, that's
a very, very simple way
to use it.
You can get started immediately.
It's as simple as writing a
cURL command and some JSON.
And then there's
Remote Procedure Calls,
which gives you more power.
Let me show you the REST API.
And this is literally
everything you
need to know to do the
REST API, on one slide.
You see on the left,
there's a JSON request,
and you can formulate that.
You can make it more
complicated, if you want,
add languages, add
different types
of ways you want to process it.
You can even add context.
A new thing we
released is the fact
that you can add new words to
the vocabulary, new phrases,
and so that's coming
out this week.
So you can make it as
complicated as you want.
But the simplest requests
would be exactly that,
those couple lines of JSON
with the content, where
you insert your audio
file or your audio data.
If you look at the bottom,
there's a cURL command.
Kind of long, but
basically, all it's posting
is a content type
and posting to a URL.
So it's taking that JSON
and posting to the URL,
and what you get back is that
response that's on your right.
And again, this is the
simplest type of response.
If all you want is
one alternative,
you don't want to see
multiple alternatives
and interim results,
you'll get something
that looks just like this.
So as I said, there's
actually two types of APIs.
The other one is the
Remote Procedure Call API.
And what that means is, you can
do everything by simply calling
methods in your
favorite language,
in either Java or C++, or the
10 different languages that are
supported.
So you don't have to
worry about the network.
And it also supports the
bi-directional streaming
that I mentioned, so
that as you're talking,
you're getting the data back.
So we support quite
a number of languages
for the Remote Procedure
Call, and this is actually
open-source.
It's free and
open-source, so if there's
a language that
doesn't appear here,
you can certainly build the
source for that language,
and actually use
it on any language.
It also uses HTTPS/2,
HTTP/2 secure,
which allows you to
have some very robust
bi-directional streaming.
So what I'd like to do
is demonstrate this.
Go straight.
Stand still.
Thank you.
I like that command.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to work it.
Sit.
Go to sleep.
So I'm going to start
that over, and we'll see.
Let me move forward.
So let me show you,
while we're waiting
for that to reboot,
exactly what we're
sending with the RPC calls.
We're sending an
initial request.
Now, this is similar
to the JSON that I
showed in the last
slide, but in here, we're
actually using proto
buffers to send this.
So it's a very compact format.
In other words,
you're not sending
extra bytes over the wire,
the way you are with JSON.
So you send your request.
You capture audio
from the microphone.
And in this case, what
we're doing is, on a thread,
we're reading a
buffer full of audio
and sending that
buffer of audio.
You will see, what we're
calling here is onNext.
So this request
observer, onNext,
is code that's automatically
supplied in any of 10 languages
so that you can keep
passing new buffers to it.
And finally, you've
got the response,
which you can be running
on a different thread,
because you're sending
audio and receiving data
at the same time.
And again, there's an
onNext command here
that's provided
automatically for you,
which provides the data.
And in this case, we're
printing out the results
of what we're receiving.
Go forward.
Spin left.
Spin right.
Go backwards.
Do a dance.
Go to sleep.
Play dead.
I like that one, too.
[APPLAUSE]
So there we are.
So one thing I
wanted to point out
is, it's responding
very quickly,
and that's because it's
streaming the speech as I'm
speaking.
So it's not going to capture
all the speech, and then wait,
and then send a big
chunk of data up.
As I'm speaking, it's going
bi-directional, and so, that's
why I can do it so quickly.
And my clicker is here.
So what I'd like to
do is-- this is easier
to show than to talk about.
So let me show this.
These are experimental
features, I want to say.
What I've showed you today
is what's available right now
on the Cloud Speech API.
These are experimental features
that will be available soon.
What time is it in Tokyo?
ROBOT: The time in
Tokyo, Japan is 9:29 AM.
GLEN SHIRES: How do you say,
"when is the next train?"
in French.
ROBOT: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
GLEN SHIRES: Turn
on the table lamp.
ROBOT: Not sure how to help
with "turn on the table lamp."
GLEN SHIRES: There we go.
Go to sleep.
So as you can see,
I've demonstrated two
different things in that demo.
The first one is spoken answers,
and what that's doing is,
as I'm asking questions,
it's providing answers.
And the second one is
something that we've actually
integrated with If This Then
That, which is a way that you
can integrate with all
sorts of different devices--
in this case, I've integrated
with a light module
controller-- so that
you can actually set up
your own triggers to do this.
And this is exactly what I did.
There's a web page
that I went to,
and I typed in what
I wanted to say
as triggers, voice triggers,
various ways I wanted
to say it, and what it's going
to respond, when I do say that.
And what it does is, it goes
out and configures this.
And now, when I speak
that phrase, or one
of those phrases, it
goes out and triggers
whatever IFTTT action you
would like to trigger.
So do you want to
go back to yours?
KAZ SATO: Yeah.
Let me try the-- I'm not
sure if it's working or not.
Maybe I can show the console.
Yeah.
Let me try again with the bot.
Oh, looks like it's working.
Yeah.
It looks like it's working.
ROBOT: It's the goose.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
It's currency.
Are you smiling?
KAZ SATO: Yes.
ROBOT: How are you?
KAZ SATO: I'm fine.
Thank you.
ROBOT: It's not [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER] It's [INAUDIBLE].
KAZ SATO: Yes, it is.
ROBOT: It's goggles.
Hello.
KAZ SATO: Not goggles.
ROBOT: It's [INAUDIBLE].
It's eyewear.
KAZ SATO: Yeah, it's eyewear.
How about this?
Yeah, if you keep smiling, then
it tries to follow towards me.
What is this?
Can you see this?
Ah.
Thank you.
So yeah, it works, finally.
ROBOT: It was [INAUDIBLE].
KAZ SATO: Yeah, thank you.
So that was our demonstration.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
KAZ SATO: OK, shall we go back?
GLEN SHIRES: Yeah.
OK.
One thing I failed to mention,
with the IFTTT triggers,
you can actually add
parameters to those triggers.
So you could add a number
or a string parameter,
and you could, for
example, tell the robot
to turn left a certain
number of steps or degrees.
So you can make the triggers,
actually, quite interesting.
So we have a number of
resources that you should
go out and take a look at.
The Cloud Vision API
and the Cloud Speech API
are ready for sign up.
And we also have-- well,
first of all, thank you--
but we also have a
number of other sessions
that are coming up that
you might be interested in.
We have code labs that talk
about machine learning.
There's several machine learning
presentations coming up.
There's Cloud
office hours, if you
want to learn more about Cloud
and integrating with the Cloud
APIs.
We have office hours
throughout the next few days,
and there's the Sandbox.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]